for us we're taking it you know 24
7. we we're living it uh throughout the
day and it's kind of
it's kind of the second child we have
three three kids
we have a alone and then we have anima
and now we have a area of the area so
yeah it's one of one of the you know
part of the family
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to the world of developers today
we're talking with savishai cohen
the ceo and co-founder of anema as a
developer then team leader then
vp rnd avishai saw again and again
that the way we're building front-end is
broken there's plenty of grunt work to
automate
that's why he started anima and designed
to code platform
allowing r d teams to convert designs
into developer friendly code
skip the boring parts and build front
end 10 times faster avishai coin
welcome to 20 minute leaders good
morning
good morning good morning happy to be
here thanks for having me
thank you for coming we're going to
start off in your army days yeah
i i usually like to start going
backwards a little bit
you flew an f-16 jet but there's also a
really a
fun story with with how you know your
your second position in the army
actually brought you all the way to what
you're doing today to anema
right right right so um
i actually started coding as a kid um
but then i didn't get to do it uh in the
military i
i joined the joined the air force um
first i went to to cool styles to pilot
first
um and then i dropped after one year
and i went to be an air traffic
controller and
it's a very interesting uh job you get
to do a lot i did get to fly
uh nf16 very exciting
and yeah i did pluto jack on
on course like pilot course but this was
this was a thrill um and actually as an
atp
i i met my wife uh michal
was today my my co-founder at anima uh
so yeah it did lead me all the way here
so we're gonna talk about uh you know
co-founding a company with with your
wife
and did the two of you also go through
the y combinator experience together
yeah yeah so we are actually three
co-founders uh
after the air force we we both went to
bercheva university
where we met our third co-founder or or
our bill
and then or and i studied computer
science and we had studied business
school
later on she went to shenkar became a
product designer and or and i are more
technical
yeah and we so we all worked at
different startups early on we
we also went to to work at big bigger
companies we
understood very fast that it was for us
and then we worked at different startups
um i was
before anima i was vpr d on a 60 percent
startup called mobley
and and yeah well over the years
in different you know position we felt
it's huge fandom it's really hard to
build front-end
um and ux today is super important
um and i guess we'll talk about animal a
lot but
but yeah we did uh start anima on 2017
and went to do y combinator on 2018
uh all of us yeah it was amazing and
so obviously you know it's not a it's
become also almost a cliche
or a well-known phrase you know software
is eating the world by by andreas and
horowitz and
and you know the the idea of prototyping
the
the intersection between front design
front-end development and backend
development you know the
this idea of full stack and and the
ability for somebody to experiment
has become so pivotal and in the life
cycle of a startup
that you know you're really and
especially i'm assuming that in y
combinator one of the things that you're
most measured by
is your ability to experiment as much as
possible right i mean that's essentially
the essence of the of this program
right definitely definitely so
yc was a great ride um
we've we stayed at stanleyville uh at
the secret conventi uh
for six months and we lived all of us
together uh
oh michal and i my kid
and orr's dog and it was pretty intense
but it was
really fun because we got to do what we
love 24 7
which is like you mentioned iterating
the product um
and yeah i think i think you you touched
you know you you asked me about
one thing like a lesson learned i think
this is the
the one thing that i take with me or
maybe you know to tell people that start
now their own startup uh to iterate as
fast as possible and we always talk
about mvp's
minimum viable products but um yeah
as faster as you iterate is as fast as
you build something people want
that's why he puts it yeah um
and so anima you're actually
facilitating that or helping facilitate
that
on the on the no code world for
designers and front-end
people tell me a little bit about this
this pain point that you've
you've been thinking about always since
uh 2017 and how did you even get
to to think through this pain point and
and become so passionate about it
sure so again i'm i i did multiple parts
as a developer then team leader then vpr
d
and also consulted at track and
and you see it all over you see when you
try to deliver
you know uh software and today
the ux expectations are really high
and and building front-end is a
you're a full stack engineer uh well you
spend
half your time doing you know logic
algorithms back and etc
and then half your time pushing pixels
so
yeah it doesn't make any sense time
pushing pixels
yeah exactly so you know as
both as an engineer and then as a leader
you see smart people
and their time is really expensive
spending half their time pushing pixels
staring at images pushing pixels and
again you mentioned the no code the no
code movement and the
low code movement and this problem has
been solved
in worlds of no code if you're building
a landing page
or you know e-commerce you have webflow
or shopify or wix
or squarespace but then if you have an
engineer involved
again they stare at images
and coding them and so we automate this
part instead of
sharing images designers keep working
with tools like adobe or figma
but then instead of sharing images they
actually share code
with engineers allowing them to deliver
10 times faster
so this is what we do um
and yeah that's that's the gist of it so
i understand
one of the one of the you know it's at
least from the way i see it you know
you're you're taking
you know they say this world of
engineering and you're changing the
the journey you're changing the the
expectations of
of the users and you're changing the
life cycle of how engineers are
interacting with designers
and the code that they're getting when
you're starting this out in 2017 and
you're starting to
to work with engineers and you're an
engineer yourself and you've facilitated
a lot of engineering
how do you how do you get the feedback
from from this new interaction
because you're really sort of almost
educating a new market that's
that's a really solid point because
everyone that starts to to solve this
problem and we're not the first ones
start with a weekly week tool so
including us
by the way um so we started we said all
right
we want to allow people to create really
rich experiences
uh and then produce code that makes
sense for engineers not
only for the browser um and so
it will be the easiest if we give them
our own environment
and this is what we started doing uh
and really early on people were really
excited about it
um but after we were released
um they ditched it after one week
so like you said you you go don't get to
change people's ways
uh that fast so really fast you realize
you need to
you know to embrace the way they're
already working um and instead of
building our own design tool
we connected to the tools they're
already working with so
be it catch or figma or adobe
we connect to this tool they already
design
you know the front end there and then on
the other end
we also don't want to tell engineers uh
how to write the code
so we are you know we don't have an
opinion uh on how the code should look
like
an engineer tells us that they are
working with react
uh they're working with style components
or not or tailwind etc
and how do you know what set of
conventions they want their code at
um and that way it's easier uh
because you don't change the way too
fast
right and so where does this actually
impact in the life cycle of a startup
because
i imagine that at the end you know
regardless of of
how great the code that you manage to
automate
and then the code that goes into
production is going to go through
various cycles of code reviews and is
going to adhere to the conventions that
that you know you're not able to tailor
and personalize to every specific
company
so where in the life cycle of the
product development
do you help expedite this 10x right
so uh maybe we will zoom out about uh
what we do we started with
giving value to to the design team
to the product team building the first
plt
prototype and now that those prototypes
we translate figma into html react
they can actually do crazy stuff they
can create
responsive designs and add videos or
maps or any you know embed code in it
and that's the first touch giving value
to a single designer
later on they share it with engineers um
and engineers today the most of
like most of the value they get is if
they're building
um new products like green field
applications
um yeah and and
like to quote one of our users uh they
got to deliver
you know six months worth of work in a
matter of two weeks
so literally 10x faster
for a new version but down the road we
will actually integrate with your github
and first pushing code like creating
pull requests
to be approved by an engineer but then
we will actually pull your existing code
base
and you know embed your existing
components
in new code so that way it makes it the
whole thing continues
does that make sense right
it does make sense and i think that what
makes most sense to me is
is going back to this idea of agility
and this idea that you know even today
we're looking at big companies
and you know they have their their line
of products but you know their their
their existence is going to be limited
if they don't continue
iterating on new products and empowering
teams and
and individuals to go and create demos
and it sounds to me that the huge added
value here in the aha moment
is this idea that within a large
organization you can still
iterate quickly and be agile and create
mvps
that even if you know even if that
second step that you're talking about
doesn't complete the cycle even that
part of being
able to deliver a product that one can
actually experiment with and even
you know potentially work with users and
show users within a matter of weeks
that's pretty amazing thanks
we chat with paul graham uh practicing
the pitch
and one of the things that he mentioned
that we we should uh
realize or emphasized is that
product market fit isn't binary here we
first
we well it's it's gradual so
if the pi and you first give value to
the most basic use cases
and designers are really happy about
anima today they get huge value out of
it
and today we focus on r d teams that are
building new products
and they are getting really excited
about it and down the road it will be
more and more complex
use cases if that makes sense no that
does make a lot of sense now
talk to me a little bit about you know
this idea of co-founding a company with
it with the friend and the wife
oh how does that work you've been you've
been doing this i guess for
three four years now yeah yeah how how
how does that how does that even work so
it works great
for us at least people some people uh uh
look at milan like uh look at that like
we're crazy but uh
for us um you know it's something we
both
are really excited about and mikhail
coming from the
the design world me coming from the
technical world
um and so for us we're taking it
you know 24 7. we're living it
uh throughout the day and it's kind of
it's kind of the second child we have
three
three kids we have a alone and then we
have anima
and now we have a area of the area so
yeah it's one of one of the you know
part of the family
i i love that and so you know when
you're when you
as you're you know co-founding obviously
there's going to be some
not not conflicts but there's going to
be disagreements on on vision or or
how the product should look or how the
pitch should look or how much money to
raise and the strategy and the vision
how are you able to separate that from
you know the the life that comes after
work
yeah so actually um i was speaking with
the founders of
honeybook they're also a married couple
um
and they told me um that
the thing the the interesting thing is
you always have conflict of conflict
with co-founders
right um and you have different opinions
and then
when you're a married couple you have to
make it work because
you you spend the you know you don't
break it so fast
it's easier for you know for uh
co-founders to split but not for a
married couple so
you're together in it no matter what
uh and also to be honest or is also like
family we we all go back
more than i don't know 14 years now uh
a good friend so yeah we're family by
now
i i love that analogy i especially know
that
i i don't know the recent statistic i
think it was the 35
of of uh of early stage companies
uh closed because of founder
disagreements the founders split
uh well here it's not it's not that
simple exactly i guess it's
i which is exactly what you're saying so
maybe it's actually an advantage so
maybe we should start looking at more
companies funded by couples well it's
been working for some of
us yeah yeah
what has been the most the most exciting
for you
throughout this journey the past four
years you've you've done quite a few
you know meaningful positions in various
organizations
as you're now running this company what
has really been the most exciting part
for you
so we started animating the bootstrap
company uh
we haven't mentioned it by now but we've
been iterating a lot
on the product before you know before we
found red
and so i think the most exciting point
was
after iterations and iterations was
you know when it all blew up so we
released the first version
our own design tool uh which was the
spaceship
not an mvp at all and so
we had to iterate really fast and take
only the parts that people liked about
it
iterated iterated and then at one point
we when we allowed design we took one
feature we allowed the designers to
create responsive designs
uh with the existing design tools uh
again because we translate it into code
if portable
so so then we published it on product
huh and it went viral
and then like this was you know
building a startup in the rollercoaster
this was one of the most exciting parts
seeing it blew up um and it leveraged
you know the whole growth came
afterwards
um and yeah we we iterated of course
a bit more than we did y combinator and
then we actually
was cash flow positive uh a year and a
half ago at the bootstrap company
wow yeah really exciting uh and at this
point we
we had to think hard if we want to
involve uh
investors or not uh but then
it's a huge space and we need to you
know we need to go
as fast as possible so we decided to
raise funds
and we grew the team from four people to
20 today
um and yeah it's wow it's been really
exciting also by the way we grew up a
lot during
during coverage which was also a crazy
you know crazy experience um
yeah i love that we do happy hours no
very
we long yeah we basically grew from four
people
like three co-founders and the first
employee
uh pablo uh into twenty so
almost everyone was there all during the
during the yeah yeah
wow yeah and we're we're a hybrid
company
like most of us are in israel today but
we have people all over
from barcelona to morocco to uh
portugal and california we're all over
incredible incredible avishai it sounds
like you're doing really
really fascinating work and then the
story behind it is is is no less
fascinating and so
and best of luck with anime thank you so
much and i have a few fun
all right before we end we'll start off
easy
favorite subject in middle school or
high school all right so
i did mention that i loved computer
science early on
but i actually didn't study it in high
school
i i did it you know on my own so
i studied electronics and physics and
the number one would be physics
because of the feature it was super
interesting uh and and
you know a brilliant person that passed
it and
physics is the the number one pick for
me
wonderful and er one of your role models
somebody that inspires you
so i know that people are saying it a
lot but
those would be my my both parents uh
who are also entrepreneurs uh build
their own business it's not
intact but they build their own business
uh
multiple businesses and today their
gurus
in their own fields um have their own
huge business
[Music]
so my parents and what are
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
all right so uh one would be family
like i'm a family guy uh and first the
father
and the husband and uh you know
and we're very we're very close to the
family
um and and that
that's really one second would be um
well well i chose software because
i love software uh like building it but
what is the name of that you mentioned
software is eating the world
and all of our especially uncovered we
we've seen that
we our lives transferred into the
virtual space
and it's it's amazing and i think the
potential is huge and
and i just love it and that's the reason
for what we like
that we're doing what we're doing we're
enabling teams to create it
better a better virtual world
so i have family i have software and i
need one more one more
so actually i chose
traveling so before covet hit
and maybe also before anima mikhail and
i
going back from
back to from the air force we got to
travel a lot so
i think we traveled over you know if you
accumulated
over two years uh in south america
middle
and central america and on the in the
east we did
uh united states europe so we love to
travel
yeah this was wonderful best of luck
with anima thank you so much
continue helping companies be more agile
and the designers and developers and
everybody in between
it sounds like a it sounds like you're
doing really great stuff thank you for
sharing
your journey thank you so much for the
opportunity likewise bye-bye